yeah how's it go Mike yeah it's good to
be on the west coast it's it's crazy out
there
you know great yeah yes well I mean I'm
west coast as well right now but yeah
New York is it's just so many people in
such a small space it's unlike anything
that we've ever seen never believe it's
crazy and you feel anything cuz they're
never gonna be over it's hard to predict
something like that so I just been
listening to what they say which is the
arc of it following you know other cases
like Han and Italy and just you know
when it takes it's it's it's tips and
peaks but it seems like this is gonna be
a very long intense battle until we
figure out better solutions with the
kids
consistently like this well that would
be a dream I'm in LA and my daughter's
and so in France right now so I didn't
want to go there risk right getting her
grandmother to because you could have it
and not know it so I didn't want to risk
jumping on an airplane and then bringing
it to them so she's safe though she's
with her mom and her grandma and they're
in France and in Paris is pretty well
structured at this point so they're
they're treating it very seriously so
not worried on that and then again it's
not really the youth that were is much
worried about it's just everybody
getting it at the same time and then the
hospitals being occupied and the staff
not being able to work and the doctors
and the nurses and everybody getting it
and then all of a sudden anybody that
has a problem can get treated
you know me thinking you can't buy I
don't think the National Guard get
involved
it's hard to say I from what I've seen
at least in LA in New York is people are
really following the rules so people are
staying in and I think they they do
understand the severity of what could
happen if all of the hospitals can't
afford to fit all of the patients
because once that happens like I said
somebody just having an asthma attack
suddenly can't get treated so what do
you think I'm living into governor como
I needed a friend maybe an infant
ventilated but they weren't workable I
hear he's handling this very well though
I hear what he's doing is incredible but
yeah we're there's a big shortage of
ventilators and the amount of patients
and their lungs people especially that
have any kind of previous lung condition
or our condition they're you know it's
atrocious it's a terrible setup and it's
like you know it's just so a nevela you
know I've been talking to hospital staff
and do magic to kids during all this so
I've been getting on FaceTime doing
magic tell the people at div them just a
little distraction but you know the mass
if they're the same mastered up the
whole day sometimes the whole week and
they're exposed to every single patient
that has corona so it's tough moment
you've never anticipated I'm sure you
never did but this is interesting to be
living the family life you know Bill
Gates did talk about this many times
over the last decade or so about that
there was gonna be a pandemic and there
was gonna be a virus that we weren't
ready to handle and you know and and and
now it's it's what he's saying his
predictions were pretty accurate so the
best thing we can hope for is that we
learn and we grown we come better and in
the world is uniting together which is a
rare thing because we're all suffering
it's not a war against each other it's
you know we're all fighting the exact
same virus so it's you know and I do
think when there's a collaborative
thought process like when everybody from
all parts of the world put their brains
on to a problem for example in 1665
during the bubonic plague in 1660
we're in London 7,000 people a week
we're just dropping dead on the street
and if you had it in your relative you
know was near you wouldn't go near them
because you were gonna die and so there
was bodies just laid out on the street
everywhere about following that was a
very serious scientific and medical
revolution so you know it does sometimes
take something this catastrophic to
unite people and I do think people are
amazing when they all put their thoughts
into one thing the way the ideas
flourish is is unprecedented so you know
there is something that you could look
at this from this is a horrible
catastrophe atrocious time that people
have to live through and suffer through
but on the tail end we might become
better as a race as he he is humans
angry down elegantly will fit yes when I
first met you Mike that you know you
said something that always changed my
life I was a kid I was I think I was
like 21 or 22 or something like that I I
met you because whether you accidentally
you but not you but your crew
accidentally took my suitcase and put it
in your in one of your cars and I said I
think my they said knock on the window
with you I'm do magic tune you said
something that was it's one of those
pivotal because you know every you know
I was like I was printing in graphic
arts your face on my shirt every time I
put the shirt you know what I was like
12 or 13 or that you know whatever so
you said I was never in it this was a
big statement and he said to me I was
never meant to be the heavyweight champ
I don't have the arm reach I'm too short
I am NOT right but I had nothing to lose
and therefore I had everything to gain
so I put everything I had in
direction and that was it and that
really inspired me and just thought it
was it was one short statement that you
made that just completely changed my
life and my focus it was it was just
what it just what a great point of view
which is give every single thing that
you have into what you believe in
so that but based on that as I'm saying
is is if humanity comes together with
that attitude if everything you have to
prevent the future of what this type of
or another type of virus could do which
is even way worse than what we could
ever imagine maybe we'll have a solution
because of this that lets us you know
challenge the almost impossible yeah I
believe a young kid you might be
successful you need Feynman to believe
in it
instant knowledge is it nothing is
impossible for somebody tries right so
that's what I'm saying is with that
attitude of you know everybody's uniting
everybody's working as hard as they can
and everybody's trying to fight one
common enemy and the enemy isn't each
other the enemy is a virus that might
help us really plan for not just this
but what might happen in the next decade
or in the next twenty years or whenever
well we hope him at a manatee learn from
history we learn from history that we
don't ever learn from history but
hopefully we will one day yeah remember
you I you showed me the levitation yeah
you said Mohammed I'll each other to you
yeah magic he had faked on my corner
with the fake thumb I didn't want to
show that trick with you you don't have
a deck of cards there do you oh you have
a deck
all right so do this hold on might take
a little group of cards don't let me see
anything don't show me and just put them
on the table in front of you just a
little group okay don't let me see your
cards
all right what I want you to do Mike is
I want you to just look at the top card
of the pile that's on the table the
little pile just look at the top card
peek at it I'm looking at the card the
first coin on top great yeah so leave it
facedown okay you agree there's no way I
can know what your card is right it's
impossible right man you'll be a god if
you know give it a good shot for like
one like like that yeah that's fine
that's good as long as it's mixed it's
good imagine this one is the card that
you thought of imagine this is your car
okay see it right here
[Laughter]
I used to do magic to it as a kid you
thought I was a vampire I was Tom I know
we were married now but some of the time
mom do we hang at heart that they me you
and Dallas Cowboy guys back in the day
oh yeah
oh my god I had a drinking competition
mr. Chau yeah man I was so crazy trying
to like compete with you yes I think you
had to carry me out of the restaurant it
was Mike Mike Mike so Mike you are also
you all you work to a rat so who wrote
your book yeah yeah and so but so you're
staying out you guys are all staying
safe and staying yeah so I you know I
think um yeah well that when this all
passes I would love to love to be able
to do magic and get back out there and
you know in the meantime it's like I
think anything that you know that they
could be done to let the people that are
in the front lines let them know how
much we all appreciate what they're
doing because it's you know it's just
crazy yeah and we have to do something
something in return
yeah but I really do feel like this is
like one of those moments where it's
terrible and as difficult as horrible is
what everything is happening I do feel
like the world will will change in the
sense that I believe that the world will
come to together and be even stronger
and better I think just I think the
upside of something like this is
actually you know you know that the
silver linings something we could never
anticipate and I really feel like that
well that's not have to happen anyone
would love to that the people could look
at people for what they are
you know me dignified he maybe
yep you have something in life that you
want to accomplish greatly you have to
be willing to give up your happiness and
especially your striving to be the best
in the world from pathology
disappointment but I'm strong and
there's nothing that could stop me
[Music]
that will come back now I'm just gonna
put my head up and face it
[Music]
[Applause]
you tell me goddess bless me that I
don't put me in this situations and I'm
you just believe they're not starting to
wake up and start and I love myself and
appreciate Who I am and what I am we go
on this ever but no I'm very grateful
that you had took the time to be able to
show what afternoon you know my pleasure
Mike my pleasure my honor like I said
when I was when I was I think 22 or
something that that you know like I said
you know that short statement that you
made was you're basically saying you're
gonna fail you're you're not meant to
succeed and you just got to keep trying
and anything that you want to do you so
just pushing and keep pushing and never
fail never give up and you know make
failure your best friend basically and
and realize that nobody's cut out to do
anything because I always thought I
always thought Mike time I always
thought to be Mike Tyson you're born
Mike Tyson no yeah but when my faith
David to say that we felt we never feel
we just learned right feeling the
feeling the audition in the media
vocabulary and I we couldn't fail to
feel we gotta put this on for you look a
jacket while you look good on a champ
you look good Mike well it's an honor to
honor to have to known you since how
many years now it's 95 so that man yeah
yeah for like 20 that's crazy yeah I
will stay safe stay quarantined keep you
know keep everybody following what you
tell them and and and I hope to see
everybody soon oh my god with you god
bless my